what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice classifying whether a
random variable is a binomial variable
and we're going to do it by looking at a
few exercises from Khan Academy so this
has a manager over she's 11 female
employees and nine male employees they
need to pick three of these employees to
go on a business trip so the manager
places all 20 names in a hat and chooses
at random let X equal the number of
female employees chosen so they're going
to do three trials and on each of those
trials you could say success is if they
pick a female employee and then the
random variable X is the number of
females out of those three is X a
binomial variable why or why not
so pause this video and see if you can
work through this on your own all right
now let's go through each choice choice
a says each trial isn't being classified
as a success of failure so X is not a
binomial variable I disagree with this
each trial is being classified as a
success or failure it's either going to
be female or not and since we're
counting the number of female employees
in a trial we pick a female that would
be a success so each trial is being
classified as a success or failure so
this one over here isn't true there is
no fixed number of trials so X is not a
binomial variable there is a fixed
number of trials they're doing three
trials they're picking three hats three
names out of a hat the trials are not
independent so X is not a binomial
variable so this is interesting so for
example trial 1 what's the probability
of success well there are 20 employees
20 names in the Hat and 11 of the
outcomes would be success so you have
eleven twentieths probability of success
but in trial two what's the probability
of success given success success in I'll
say trial 1 t1 well if you succeeded in
trial 1 that means that there's now only
10 female names in the Hat out of 19 and
if you don't have success in trial 1
then you
have then it will be 11 out of 19 so
your probability does change based on
previous outcomes and so the trials are
not independent and so X is not a
binomial variable so this one is true
the trials are not independent so that
violates that condition for being a
binomial variable in order to be a
binomial variable all your trials have
to be independent of each other and so
we'd rule this last one out because this
last one says that X has a binomial
distribution or it is or does meet all
the conditions for being a binomial
variable let's do another example so
here we have different scenarios and I
have the conditions for binomial
variable lit written right over here and
so once again pause the video and look
at each of these scenarios for random
variables and look at these conditions
and think about whether these random
variables are binomial or not so let's
look at the first one and a game
involving a standard deck of 52 playing
cards an individual randomly draws seven
cards without a replacement let Y be
equal to the number of aces drawn well
in our introductory video to binomial
variables we talked about if we're doing
without replacement your probability of
getting an ace on us on a given trial
when your wear trial is you're taking a
card out of the deck it's going to be
dependent on whether you got aces in
previous trials because if you got an
ace in a previous trial well that ace
then you're gonna have fewer aces in the
decks so the the trials in this case are
not independent not in the pendent not
independent trials now on the other hand
if on every trial you looked at whatever
card you got and put it back in the deck
then they would be in two independent
trials the Trott the probability of
getting an ace on each trial would be
the same but not when you have without
replacement so this is not not binomial
right over here because you don't have
independent trials the second scenario
60% of a certain species of tomato live
transplanting from pot to garden Eli
transplants 16 of these tomato plants
assume that the plants live
independently of each other so whether
one plant lives isn't dependent on
whether another plant lives let T equal
the number of tomato plants that live
all right so let's look at the
conditions the outcome of each trial can
be classified as either success or
failure so each trial over here is one
of the tomato plants and we have 16 of
those trials and success is if the
tomato plant lives and failure is if it
dies so we have either success or
failure each trial is independent of the
others they tell us the plants live
independently of each other so whether
or not a neighboring plant lives or dies
doesn't affect whether the plant next to
it lives or dies
so each trial is independent of the
others there's a fixed number of trials
yes we have 16 right over there the
probability P of success on each trial
remains constant
well yeah according to at least the
scenario they're saying that we have a
60% chance for each tomato plant which
is each trial so it meets all of the
conditions right over here so this one
is binomial now let's look at this third
scenario in a game of luck a turn
consists of a player continuing to roll
a pair of six-sided die until they roll
a double two of the same face values let
X equal the number of rolls in one turn
so you're gonna keep rolling until they
roll a double well the thing that jumps
out at me is that you don't have a fixed
number of trials not fixed number of
trials you could say each trial each
roll as a trial success is getting a
double which has a fixed probability
whether or not you get a double on each
trial is going to be independent of the
previous roll so it meets all the other
constraints but it does not meet that
there's a fixed number of trials you're
gonna keep someone there's some chance
you might have to roll 20 times you are
200 times or or or who knows however
many times until they roll a double and
so this violates there's a fixed number
of trials so since there is not a fixed
number of trials this variable X naught
by no Meah